[Musique]
au coeur de la plaine des palmistes à la
maison du parc national une convention
est tout juste signé entre la spl eden
et le parc national de la réunion est
grande de la convention avec la spa
leader c'est réellement travaillé sur
les espèces exotiques envahissantes
travailler sur la connaissance qu'est ce
qui se passe en termes de dynamique sur
les haies sur les espaces il était quand
vincent la connaissance par rapport à la
capacité à lutter et à restaurer les
milieux et puis aussi créer de
l'activité économique et de l'emploi
autour de la délégation s'est ensuite
rendue au tampon au parc des paniers
pour la présentation du projet
d'extension du domaine et le lancement
du projet en des miels appuyée par la
spl eden le projet endémicité approché
de 3 6 km
[Musique]
le niveau 2 400 m d'altitude à 1750
mètres d'altitude ceux d'orange et de
jeu tournée mme x 960 km 2 de aef que
nous allons mettre au service des
plantes ministère
[Musique]
le président de la fédération nationale
des entreprises publiques locales a
rencontré les élus du département à la
saphir afin d'échanger sur la
problématique de la gestion des
ressources en eau et des périmètres
irrigués à la réunion nous avons
beaucoup de singularité sur le
territoire de la réunion et oui l'eau on
doit aller chercher dans nos montagnes
faire des chantiers colossaux faire des
tunnels passer sous sous ces montagnes
pour ramener de l'eau aux abonnés
puisque nous faisons nous que quelqu un
lien entre le captage là où nous prenons
cette eau cet or blanc et que nous
livrons ensuite offert mais des communes
pour que ce soit livrée chez chez les
abonnés une journée de visites et de
rencontres au coeur des actions de la
spl éden qui s'achève par l'inauguration
de la première pépinière départementale
qui proposera des plantes endémiques et
indigènes de la réunion pour le grand
projet porté par le département planter
un million d'arbres d'ici à 2027 un
travail pour l'avenir
et pour la biodiversité pour retrouver
aussi
nos armes d'antan et faire en sorte que
ça soit un patrimoine qui est une vraie
transmission et en fera travailler aussi
les jeunes des écoles sur ces
plantations on a déjà commencé mais on
va continuer et ce sera une
représentation réussie par tous et
respect des dead apporte son expertise
alliés en plus transition écologique
insertion parle par l'emploi et pmm
lutte vectorielle donc ça c'est vraiment
une création unique en france et moi je
suis à peu près certain que sont sondés
un exemple ça va être un exemple qui va
donner l'envié sans doute à d'autres
endroits à ce que ont créé des outils
comme cela pour ses actions de lutte
anti-vectorielle et la promotion d'un
écosystème social et environnemental la
spa laden a remporté le trophée des ep
hell en 2021
[Musique]